French president Manuel McCrone hopes
tax relief and other fiscal measures
will calm violent nationwide protests
there the reforms are expressed expected
to cost around 10 billion euros French
ambassador to the United States Gerardo
roux
joins me here on set mr. ambassador
thanks for being here
first this breaking news out of
Strasbourg there's a death toll now The
Associated Press has it that for
shooting in a Christmas market suspect
wounded anything it says a terrorism
investigation well apparently well you
know I don't have of course news it has
been it has happened a few hours ago the
suspect has not been arrested we know
who he is you know apparently is an
Islamist terrorist is chased there are
three or maybe four people who have been
killed but at least 12 have been wounded
we have been facing this challenge for
some time now unfortunately the threat
from radical article Islamism yes he's
still there I want to turn to the
protests it seems I mean here is the
French president in his address to the
nation tickle song I feel the anger give
us another chance
it's a zoo I want to see an immediate
and real improvement in the salaries and
this is why I am ordering in the end of
the year bonus for all employees with
health any tax
you know he's increasing minimum wage
proposal tax cuts for retirees other
concessions as well and yet it doesn't
seem like that stopping the protests you
know in a sense the powder keg of the
explosion was more or less what we are
seeing in the u.s. in UK we proceeded
everywhere we have in France like into
like in this country and elsewhere we
have millions of citizens who consider
that be left being left behind by
globalization automation you know it's
the lower middle class the people living
in small cities in who warriors and they
are hovering and and they have been
rebelling also against our government
the government of president macro with
we as we know we has been trying to
reform reform France
so that I think that's the the social
background of the crisis it was
interesting to watch politicians and
people here in this country especially
on the left because this started as a
climate change effort this fuel tax near
a tendon with the Center for American
Progress tweeted I don't understand why
any progressive is cheering French
protesters who are amassing against a
carbon tax
there was a real divide about how to do
that if you want to tackle it especially
if you're coming from the left side of
at least American politics well you know
in French politics the protesters are
saying we are serious about ourselves
about fighting climate change but
basically they say you know one of them
said something very special
he said we are concerned about the end
of the world but we are also concerned
about the end of the month yeah so
really and it's full of common sense
when you are increasing the price of gas
for for the people especially for the
people living in rural areas it has
consequences on the standard of living
and I think that's what the French
government t-take didn't take into
account so now I think the president has
decided to face this this problem right
so he lists all these concessions he
says I'm sorry
he wants to do all of these different
things yet it doesn't seem to be
appeasing the protesters which have cost
your country a lot of money in tourism
and in shopping and everything else for
friends are very good demonstrators and
that's in tradition you know in our
country we are going to see you know and
of course there are other always people
who will not satisfy what with what the
president has decided but I think we are
going to see in the coming days whether
these demonstrations are going to be as
strong as they were last week the
relationship between President Trump and
President macron largely talked about
when there - visited that was very warm
you had the Prime Minister the Foreign
Minister rather saying I say to Donald
Trump the French president told him as
well we don't take part in American
debates let us live our life in our
entry that message said I guess after
the tweets he sent out about France well
you know in in a family you have very
good squabbles
so in the franco-american relationship
you have berms we have had berms you
have burned but fundamentally the
relationship between the two countries
remain excellent and I still talk and
they still talk they talk a lot on the
phone
yes I want to turn to another foreign
policy issue and that is Iran they've
just tested some long-range ballistic
missiles France was actually on the
forefront of really cracking down on
Iran and the nuclear agreement where do
you see Iran today and what could be
happening you know basically what we
have been telling our American friends
is that we take very seriously what the
Iranians are doing in terms of missile
activities in terms of terrorism in
terms of regional aggression and that we
were ready to work with with with the
American on that there was a negotiation
actually between the three main European
countries and the US only on this issue
so we are still ready we are still ready
to work with the American on really we
share one represent the concerns on the
of the Americans do you think a deal is
going to be repurposed we really
basically we say we do consider that the
decision of the American administration
to get out of the orange ear was a bad
decision but we hope that we can work
together on the other issues I have
really I've referred to terrorism
regional activities and missiles and
actually there are negotiations between
the Europeans and the Americans on these
issues
well mr. ambassador we appreciate your
time thank you very much thank you